la oposición hongkonesa recibió el mayor
golpe de los últimos meses 53 miembros
cercanos al movimiento prodemocrático
fueron arrestados la excusa de las
autoridades es que estas personas
intentaron socavar al gobierno con la
celebración de unas primarias
clandestinas de cara a los comicios
legislativos que se iban a celebrar en
septiembre de 2020 wi-fi hemos arrestado
a 53 personas por los delitos de
subversión bajo la ley de seguridad
nacional
así nos ayudó también a funding son
equipo chapín down eso significa que
estamos encontrando que algunas personas
han estado interfiriendo seriamente
interrumpiendo y socavando el
funcionamiento del gobierno de hong kong
por medio de un plan para pain
en estas elecciones finalmente no se
realizaron con el pretexto de la
pandemia y permitieron seguir
conservando el poder en la cámara al
partido oficialista de carril am el
hecho de que las detenciones se
produjeran bajo la acusación de violar
la ley de seguridad nacional es grave ya
que ésta contempla la cadena perpetua en
casos de intento de secesión o
confabulación con fuerzas extranjeras
una decisión que impactó a la ciudadanía
al ver las noticias hoy me sentí
completamente conmocionada me siento muy
decepcionada están sucediendo cosas muy
importantes en hong kong y no hay nada
que podamos hacer al respecto
hong kong lleva más de año y medio de
protestas contra lo que la oposición
considera una regresión de la democracia
y un acercamiento a los postulados de
beijing